you want to make the fan one of the
essential since you've already got it ya
know what about what else your boyfriend
want 10 these are my century hat
[Music]
obviously these one of them I stay cool
I ain't no they're not like this all
sometimes you know that keep it real
with yourself don't do that oh I thought
that thought young whip outlook on never
them seems with the most important
things for my sense was that like to
keep in my pocket everything played on a
different part it different reason and
you get tough what's your hairline in
the book in the car behind you noticing
that definitely make sure up there down
five uh sometimes yeah here when you got
that good hair go today I might go to
the left might go to the right and they
give a moment this is no your lips can
never look like be about the cracking
these lovers you never have chapped lips
with no excuse for it there's no reason
why you should be walking around which
it looks like that you can never have
your breath smell like you want your
breath go ruin everything for you a
business deal
late night we might have everything
right now so you open your mouth you
know you lose everything
yeah it's like that
and this right here very important when
everything started going getting too
crazy whatever is a better night my
little lavender pouch is this smell that
I love and was just well like this just
calm down smooth your body out this
right here I can never show you the name
I don't know why they've been doing this
this cologne that I got in India and
ever since I first put it on it was just
the best now I have a smell you know
every time I hug somebody feel the same
way they want to find out but I'm not
giving them with where they get it from
I know I might be the first one to show
you these but it was very necessary they
saved my death you never know what can
happen in ever a little pop up you know
everybody you know
think use not porn but he's very
important enjoy yourself
we'll enjoy yourself safely especially
the lifestyle with that you know break
[Laughter]
this one has some special you know
coming from New York and just like you
know always going to see this one
I don't let anyone by the way so you
know how much hello
usually used to go to Fordham Road
document uptown all the Dominicans and
you know this this office would be like
you know the number one thing basically
something that bring everybody together
just like how some people play dominoes
how some people do it like a traditional
you know culture thing although Ciroc
although 1942 and okay okay when I'm
done doing all the interviews in the
shows and like to be comfortable in
relax
it's the best doing some China citizen
Egyptian cloth and microfiber boss and I
lose a lot like it stolen like it
misplaced it's not in his room if you
will also wear sandals and I was up
being comfortable especially my own
sanctuary my own awesome you just happen
to be a water one beside Santos it
you know my god he saw me you know
there's a mixing you know he wanted to
make something special for me so these
were sake 101 that he didn't ever see
these again somebody look up to you know
something that you know make something
to make you an exclusive it's like going
to the club you know gonna be happy so
this is what it's hot I mean I guess you
gotta look good when you travel at the
end of the day still not closing it and
it represents your family this right
here is the new collection and I hate
traveling so I already don't like
looking at luggage but there's still one
of my favorite dancers basketballs look
like one of my favorite sandwich places
I just woke up crazy coming from the
y'all get on the thing used to do is
just go walk up to the corner spot
bodega and get a sandwich and get a soda
and some salt vinegar chips and barbecue
chips I'm told there was something
accessible to us especially if he was a
hustler on the Block in school right
that's a normal man you know them Porto
Ricans Dominicans made the best
sandwiches it's hot fuss I had to find
it going but when you do you stay stay
home so so this summer fell in love with
like gonna start making music though
sometimes I have to after all these long
days in studio we just sit there just
you know slow play with it I never took
classes through our songs inflection or
certain things because I always want to
follow the sound you know music is a
language and I just know how to play it
with Maya
and I saw playing it became with a
therapy thing and sometimes I would just
be you know have a glass of wine just
play guitar and just foot flow let me
flow this out
[Music]
obviously you know when you ride around
each I listen to music whatever I write
you wanna pull up right I want the new
windows even on the car he's gotta stop
you know paint what some money just
happy we're doing a lot I always been a
fan of all phantoms
I mean why not the one that came over to
Conrad's just like most babies heat and
and after the biggest diamond let the
other found no way it works it works and
and you know his growth even though a
lot of people go kind of like but you're
wasting your money isn't that I felt
like was the reason making wonder if you
can buy things you know you want to
dream about it was working then here
goes as everybody on the animal doll I
love animals
and since I was young I was hands off
but this is my first time being a
massive I always been a fan of I just
wanted to see like how can adult in this
big I never thought that you know a
dolphin would reach 300 pounds by
sometimes I'd be in the backyard he was
fake I swear he's he's not months old
you know like a bear and without walking
he was be like what is this especially
people have to walking like a little
chihuahua
yeah chair that might be my number one
you know like my kid
[Applause]